many people might not remember but when
it was founded in 1995
amazon.com was originally an online
bookstore
in a quarter of a century founder jeff
bezos made it the world's
biggest retailer putting countless high
street brick
and mortar stores out of business amazon
made shopping faster cheaper and easier
the company's success made bezos the
richest man in the world
and the first person in history to
accrue a net worth of 200 billion
dollars in any environment there's
always an opportunity to
innovate and to disrupt and to
you know reshape the way the industry
works i mean certainly
amazon is not the first nor is it the
last innovator who will disrupt the
market
but you know what's significant about
what jeff bezos has done
is the magnitude of that disruption you
know there are very few markets
um that are have been left untouched
in some way as a result of what amazon
has become
bezos steps down as amazon is posting
record profits
thanks to a rise in online purchases
during covid 19 lockdowns around the
world
amazon quarterly sales have reached more
than 100 billion dollars
for the first time but just weeks
earlier he lost the title
of world's richest person to another
tech entrepreneur
elon musk founder of automaker tesla and
space flight company spacex
[Music]
in 2000 two years earlier than spacex
bezos founded his own aerospace company
blue origin
and just like amazon the company aims to
make space flight
cheaper easier and more accessible what
he said in a letter to amazon employees
that he's going to stay with the company
as executive chairman but he wants to
pursue other things including
helping amazon launch new products so
being a bit of a visionary starting up
new projects
also the washington post which he owns
he also owns a company that's uh
getting competing in the space race uh
privatization of space so
he has a lot of interest and i think he
wants to be free to pursue the interests
while at the same time keeping his hand
in amazon
whatever is next for bezos one thing is
certain he is more than likely to keep
making
staggering sums of money estimated
earnings from amazon have him on track
to become the world's first trillionaire
by 2026.
zayn basravi al jazeera